ever since Apple's WWDC event everyone's
been talking about Apple switching to
their own ARM processors and wondering
which Mac computers will be the first
ones coming with custom Apple chips
later this year but people are
forgetting that Apple also mentioned
that there are still some great intel
powered macs in the pipeline and we
still as as Tim said we still got some
intel-based macs to introduce right that
were super proud of and this transition
is going to take a couple of years and
seeing as Apple's transition to their
own ARM chips will be complete two years
from now we can only wonder which Mac's
will be the last ones ever to come with
Intel chips there were so many leaks and
rumors pointing to Apple releasing a
brand new iMac at WWDC and quite a few
people were sure of it but it never
happened
so I think Apple decided not to release
it at the last minute and I personally
believe that that Mac is actually an
Intel based iMac and I think it's coming
with in the next month
and yes I completely agree with all of
the leaks and rumors that a totally
redesigned 24 inch iMac powered by a
custom Apple chip is going to be coming
at the end of the year but I think the
current 27-inch iMac is going to be
refreshed one last time with an Intel
chip and it's going to go out with a
bang so I'm gonna give you guys five
reasons why I think a new Intel iMac is
coming within the next month and then
we'll talk about which specs and
features we should expect in this new
iMac but before we begin I want to
mention that you can find our new Apple
product pattern t-shirts in our merch
shelf right below this video it all
started back in March when a reliable
leaker coin X tweeted out that a new
iMac and Mac Mini are coming soon well
the Mac Mini was updated with more
storage on March 18th
but obviously nothing happened to the
iMac so it could have been that Apple
was planning to release it but they
delayed it for some reason now the
second reason why I think in iMac is
coming soon as on on June 11th album
made regulatory filings to the EEC dead
for nine iPhones and one desktop Mac
which is something that they are
required to do every single time they
ship a device with built-in encryption
and this usually means that a hardware
release is coming soon on October 25th
of 2018 Apple made AEC filings for a few
devices including model numbers a 21 15
and a 21 16 which turned out to be the
2019 IMAX which were released on march
19th of 2019 but this time there is only
one model number instead of two so it
could be that only one of the IMAX sizes
is going to get updated in this totally
makes sense since we're expecting the 24
inch iMac powered by Apple's new ARM
chip to come later this year
so Apple releasing a 27 inch Intel based
iMac within the next month would totally
make sense and that one Mac in the
filing is noted as running Mac OS 10.15
and this small detail is very important
because as you all know the upcoming Mac
OS big sir is now actually Mac OS 11
which will be released this fall so this
points to this Mac releasing before the
release of Mac OS big sir now you might
be wondering why I'm expecting this new
iMac to be released within the next
month and that brings me to my third
reason On June 10th the 27-inch iMac
went completely out of stock for every
single model with a ship date of over
two weeks later on June 25th just three
days after WWDC pointing to a new iMac
getting released at that event but what
makes it even more interesting is that
as of right now that ship date has
slipped to July 13th on the base 27-inch
model and the higher-end models are all
the way out in August which is
completely the opposite of what you'd
expect if something truly goes out of
stock and knowing that Apple is only
releasing their arm Mac's closer to the
end of the year it would be insane for
Apple to keep the 27-inch iMac out of
stock for that many months
unless of course they're planning to
release a new model very soon which
would have to be an intel-based iMac now
on to my fourth reason there were quite
a few rumors and leaks pointing to a new
iMac coming at WWDC like John Prosser
who said an iMac was ready to ship which
obviously isn't the arm Mac since we
know what's coming at the end of the
year Sawney Dickinson also mentioned a
new iMac coming at WWDC but the
important part about that rumor is that
he mentioned the new iMac getting a t2
chip and in AMD Navi GPU now I'm pretty
positive that apples are Mac's are gonna
use their own custom graphics chips
instead of using an AMD navi GPU and
Apple even showed a slide during WWDC
where it mentions a high performance arm
GPU meaning that they're not planning to
use an AMD GPU on there are Macs and on
top of that those new Macs are not going
to need the t2 chip because the new ARM
chips are going to take care of
everything that the t2 chip used to do
so based on those two things it seems
like this iMac rumor that was supposed
to drop at WWDC is actually an Intel
based iMac that Apple chose to delay and
this brings me to my final reason why we
should expect a new Intel based iMac
within a month a couple of months ago
Twitter user Rho game discovered some
new code in Mac OS 10 point 15 point 4
beta one which pointed to support for
AMD s
unreleased Navi 21 graphics cards
showing that Apple is planning to bring
new AMD cards to a desktop Mac in the
near future and on top of that Intel is
already shipping 10th gen processors
including the I 9 10 at 900k which would
be perfect for a high-end 27-inch iMac
so if Apple were to release a new iMac
with these new Intel processors and new
AMD graphics cards people would be all
over it even while knowing that Apple
ARM chips are coming within the next two
years and as far as the specs we should
likely expect the fusion drive to
disappear in favor of SSD option
we should expect an upgrade to Bluetooth
5 and Wi-Fi 6 connectivity support for
apples 6k Pro display XDR and maybe even
an option for 10 Gigabit Ethernet now
the final question is if this iMac will
stick to the same 27-inch design or if
it will get smaller bezels to pack in a
larger display or maybe even a full
redesign and for that I don't really
know but what I do know is that the
chances of a new Intel based iMac
replacing the current 27-inch iMac
within the next month are very high but
if you totally disagree with me go ahead
and comment your thoughts down below and
be sure to check out our new t-shirts
down in the merch shelf thanks for
watching click the circle above to
subscribe and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]